i believe it's a general truth that when
people focus so much on stuff that's
fleeting
such as physical beauty which once again
we're all going to get older absolutely
man right
absolutely and when you put an emphasis
on that so much what does that do to you
mentally
right where does that put your value on
as a person as a human being which by
the way
like a lot of men have a responsibility
in this as well because some of the
dudes out there say some of the dumbest
[ __ ] they go
i don't like it when girls wear makeup
that's funny because you're the one
that's jacking off
these girls on instagram so you kind of
set that standard for what beauty is
in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
excuse me you're welcome apologies man
you know what it's so funny now that we
talked about this mike tyson thing
you know what so this morning yeah i
woke up from a dream
that i was boxing mike tyson hey let me
tell you about this [ __ ] dude
did you die because that's what happened
because we knew mike tyson
is on dmt and [ __ ] smoking weed so he's
super nice but we're boxing
yeah in the middle of uh of a vegas
casino
okay right and so we're kind of boxing
and he's kind of letting me light him up
he's letting me do it he's being super
nice so i'm just over here throwing
combos
you know straight to the body and the
reason why i'm saying he's letting me do
this
in the dream yeah i i ducked under one
of his hooks
i hit two light hits to the body because
he's letting me hit him so we're going
light
up and then i kind of kept my hands down
and then tyson looks at me and you just
see this
[ __ ] right hook come to my face and
he just he's grimacing like his teeth
are just tight yeah
and he stops the punch right before my
face and he just starts smiling i'm like
in that dream i shat myself yeah that's
a that's a terrifying
[ __ ] you know situation
you know letting me hit him up a little
bit and then were you guys sparring or
was this like a
like it was like an event okay but it
was weird it was in the middle of a
casino and there was you know there's
like a few hundred people watching yeah
but it wasn't like a packed arena or
anything it was in the middle of a
casino like
literally middle of a casino on the
floor in the casino floor okay
and in the middle tyson just goes i left
something in my car after i get it
come with me david in the middle of the
[ __ ] fight so as we're going uh
to his car outside in the parking lot
where we're i'm trying to talk to him
and i'm trying to segue into a
conversation where i could just talk
really light to him yeah but i'm just
like hey
you know mike like i loved watching you
box you know later on in your life like
when you were i was super young so i
didn't get to see a lot of your earlier
fights but you know i saw a lot of the
read ones i became a huge fan
i was like my boy pj like you you
shouted them out i'm trying to make this
connection just desperate as [ __ ] right
yeah but he's being super [ __ ] nice
to me like super chill yeah
right and the crazy thing is in the
dream mike tyson starts dropping like
these
these gems of knowledge on me and i'm
like as he does though
as he does he's an intelligent guy man
so i was telling him it's like yo man i
don't know how you
do boxing like it's such a spectacle
it's very difficult for people to
perform
you know specifically as a performance
sport and also as one of the most
dangerous sports out there which is
boxing all these blows to the head yeah
hey let me tell you something um the
reason why we do what we do he's talking
to me as if i'm a boxer
right because it's because 99 of people
can't do what we do
and the rest like you and me were
winners
those people they're [ __ ] losers
because those people they watch this
there's a spectacle yeah they just kind
of watch what we do
and they wish what we they could do what
we do but they can't so they [ __ ]
losers david
and i'm just sitting there like damn
that [ __ ] deep son
this isn't my dream yeah and i woke up
and actually wrote it in my phone
because of what he said and i'm like
damn this [ __ ] i feel like he
did dmt and he flew into my head yeah
doc where did i write that [ __ ] i
literally wrote it down
oh maybe oh you know what i wrote it in
a group chat to my buddy
okay let me show you exactly what he
[ __ ] said hold on a second but i mean
it's not uh
what you're saying isn't isn't really
like far-fetched from you know some of
the things
he he he would say or have said
watch what this fool said he dropped
knowledge he goes so i kind of wrote to
these dudes
he goes in the middle of the fight we
went to the parking lot to get something
and he was explaining to me
how most people in life are [ __ ]
losers he said look at this boxing match
we're doing in the middle of the day
people watch us because they can't do
what we do they have opinions about
something they could never do in their
lives so they feel better about
themselves
i'm like damn yo mike tyson deep as [ __ ]
he said this to me in my dream yeah
watch if i meet him in person and be
like did you remember what i said
no but like some of the things he said
to you in your dream are things he's
he's actually talked about yeah yeah so
it's it's like it's not far-fetched at
all i mean
that's like completely in line with
something mike tyson would say
and has said um in the past and man like
speaking of mike dude i remember
um towards like the tail end of his
career that fight against lennox i
actually ordered that pay-per-view
oh did you yeah yeah so this is when i
was in high school still i think
and then um you know just invited people
over to watch it
it was so [ __ ] disappointing man i
was like dude mike
what happened to you man because like i
wasn't a fan of boxing when i was like
in elementary or anything
but growing up in the 90s you knew who
the [ __ ] mike tyson was yeah you know
and ferocious youngest heavyweight
champion
yeah and like even if you didn't watch
all his fights
you know you caught random like clips
here and there of like how destructive
his power was
and so like you know we didn't know or i
didn't know
that mike was really at that point in
his career
to me in my mind was this industrial
mobile [ __ ] is gonna kill this
guy he's gonna bite his i don't even
know who lennox lewis was
right okay yeah because i wasn't
familiar with the boxing world like
i only knew like headliner names like
oscar de la hoya you know
uh what was it floyd uh floyd mayweather
you know
mike tyson and so in my mind i was
thinking dude mike's gonna [ __ ] wreck
this dude
and then yes it was
this pretty sad thing to watch man it
was hard he was at the tail end of his
career
yeah he got out classed completely linux
lewis had uh
an amazing jab and i actually use uh
lettuces when i spar i use lennox's
lewis
linux with lewis i use i use his jab
style which is like
it's very odd because you'll see people
with like a tight shell and i'm pretty
sure boxing experts can agree with this
but this is what i've seen from when i
watched lennox lewis box
and you'll see him train people he he
has like a half jab meaning that he
actually
already extends half his jab out yeah so
he pops people with it really well
uh-huh and with somebody with mike tyson
who fights on the inside yeah just
manages distance right right lex lewis
had that jab that would manage distance
yeah
super [ __ ] good and he had to hide in
length against him too for sure but that
was always with mike though michael's
always a shorter guy he's actually a
very very short heavyweight right right
that's why he had that weird peekaboo
style what he would get
yeah yeah yeah his head movement was
crazy you know dude the roy jones jr he
still got it yeah
it's [ __ ] nuts watching him move like
that at the age of almost 60.
like what the hell how do you move this
wheel how do you
how are you still in this like peak
shape that people could only hope and
dream for
in their prime and they got tested for
steroids he's fine
like how the [ __ ] does he not have
steroids he's just a specimen yeah he's
just a [ __ ] specimen like
the dude is gifted with like physical
prowess
and and he's that's why he's able to
still do that at [ __ ] 55 years old or
whatever oh i'm still always amazed
about how [ __ ] smart he is dude
yeah especially when he speaks it's just
so refreshing like
the way he was talking to me in that
dream dude that [ __ ] was knowledge right
there yeah
the point where i wrote it down yeah so
i mean here's here was the thing with
mike
like throughout his life was that you
know he he's a he's a
very like well-read guy right there's a
lot of reading he knows his [ __ ]
but because he was in prison oh yeah all
he had was a dictionary to read every
day
no the the difference the difference
between
like polarizing and ridiculous mic and
intelligent mic it's just a fine line
and it's really ego
once the ego is removed out of it right
once iron mic
is removed out of it he can see can
speak very calmly intelligently
once you inject the ego part of it the
emotion part of it
and like the status part of it then he
says some really outlandish [ __ ]
that makes him come across as like just
a ridiculous guy
he was born in the wrong generation he
should have been born like
like 300 years back he would have been a
marauder he would have been a king of
some land
just dominating just just literally
just having 36 whip concubines yeah
having 80 children all the time he just
comes in a ship by himself
i'm here to dominate you guys i'm here
to take over
i'm just going to come here and just
beat everybody there
no spears no guns no nothing biting ears
off wearing it as a necklace is
what i do but you know what happened
recently what people wanted to talk
about for us to talk about and
i saw a lot of these stuff on on twitter
was emye
yeah kanye kenye right which i don't
know why people ever get surprised that
celebrities break up
like this is something that's it's
almost like a definite i'm more
surprised
when celebrities stay together yeah for
sure that's that's more uncommon
because like the i mean what we just
talked about how
different their world is and just like
how strange their life is when you kind
of mirror it against
normal life yeah um it's it's a it's
it's a surprise that they don't [ __ ]
go crazy
and that they could hold normal
relations or something because i feel
like when you have that much money in
power
it's like why not yeah who are you to
tell me i can't do this
i'm [ __ ] rich i'm bald and i have
power like people literally do
whatever i tell them to do yeah why the
[ __ ] can i go ahead and
[ __ ] a horse you know how come this
baboon can come over here and jerk me
off while i'm eating my sandwich
like i don't i think this is like the
weird [ __ ] that rich people think about
yeah that and i think that's why there's
rumors about
like i think there was a rumor that john
legend was like bisexual or some [ __ ] oh
yeah i remember that
what wasn't that from like kind of the
tell-all like that girl who
like slept with all these people in
hollywood and then she just kind of
wrote a book about it
kind of uh exposing something like yeah
i just remembered
that it was something like that and
there were it was multiple people it
wasn't just josh
yeah yeah it wasn't like eddie murphy
was in there you know uh jamie foxx or
something
like that too yeah so it was it was
i don't know how much credibility and
truth there is to it but
i wouldn't be surprised to tell you the
truth you know do you know who uh
jeffrey star is
no who's so jeffree star is this huge i
guess like
he did music with um with like nicki
minaj had a collab with her and some
[ __ ]
but jeffrey starr is uh he's actually a
huge makeup makeup brand person
so i was like a multi-million dollar
makeup brand wow huge gigantic
fallen out of his [ __ ] mind there was
a rumor going on
that the reason why kim kardashian and
uh kim k and kanye broke up was because
he was uh sleeping with this dude
jeffrey starr
and jeffree star is like a huge social
media guy that's where he started off
from okay
so that was like this big rumor that was
going on because i guess they live in
the same state in like wyoming or
something or they own like same property
and there was a few tweets back in the
day saying like yo it was great meeting
you or whatever
but the rumor went around that kim
kardashian or kanye was cheating on kim
k
with jeffree star he was getting his
sick his dick sucked by this dude
isn't that [ __ ] nuts oh man it's it
to a normal person yes to to for their
standards and their
lifestyle not so much you know i'm
saying sometimes i wonder too because
uh i i guess it was put out because
jeffree star is like this is the dumbest
thing ever what because we had the same
house in the same state
oh he actually commented on it yeah
because he said this was like the most
stupidest [ __ ] rumor he's ever heard
in his life yeah right
and then [ __ ] uh how it started was
from a tick-tock star
uh you do you remember once people were
going around licking uh
toilet seats yes during the corona thing
yes so this is the tick tock star that
started that oh my god
so this tick tock starts like whole
career is based off doing stupid [ __ ]
yeah
right because the only talent that they
have is to get attention yeah
so lindsay just threw the rumor out
there through the rumor out there and so
i guess like that's
what this person's new thing is is
starting rumors
that that definitely doesn't surprise me
and 100 i'm almost a thousand percent
sure because
this person went public and said that
it's completely fake like
you know i was just bored i was like on
some [ __ ] and i just said i'm pretty
sure kanye's team legal illegally
contacted her
for libel and slander yeah so if you
don't take this [ __ ] down we're gonna
[ __ ] up your whole life yeah
and so that's i'm a million percent sure
that's what happened i mean they they
should have pressed
charges against them you know uh i mean
these peop these people need to be
holding
held accountable for their actions man
you can't just you know act like you can
just say whatever the [ __ ] you want and
get away with it because you have a
platform
one of my favorite things to look up on
youtube is pranksters getting their ass
beat
that's like by that's my favorite [ __ ]
dude
when they [ __ ] with the wrong person and
they end up like like
getting the [ __ ] beating out yeah i
don't know why i like it so much yeah it
feels so satisfying
that just reminded me of that guy um uh
you know that that youtuber
um [ __ ] magic of rahat or something
like that
that indian dude who used to do magic
you know out in the streets and [ __ ]
like that
he was he was a pretty big youtuber you
don't remember i hate magic dude okay
okay well anyway like you have one card
and then two cards
no no no he's not like that uh but yeah
he recently resurfaced and and i guess
there was this he took this long hiatus
for like two years because
there were accusations of um a homeless
guy that he had helped
so he helped his homeless guy by giving
him um
a house or a place to live and then i
remember this video went viral yeah yeah
so he's a magician
yeah he's a magician i think his name is
rahat let me let me look it up just to
be sure but
he he was a big youtuber bro i'm pretty
sure you've seen
i know that video though but you know i
don't know i've never really watched
youtube that much
except for you know stupid yeah it's
magic of rahat that's his name
but anyway yeah there was like that uh
the whole controversy was that
he raised money for this homeless guy he
was trying to help
um and then the homeless guy
turned around and basically said yeah he
didn't give me
that money and like he basically [ __ ]
me over
and uh really so he just did like a
stunt video
that that's what the homeless guy was
claiming okay right so
it's uh he smoked it all away no and
then and then he
recently this guy rohat came back uh
resurfaced and is addressing those
claims
and basically he never addressed it
before yeah so he he just basically went
quiet
and went dark for two to like two years
um
do my biggest act yet i'm gonna
disappear
watch my career go go away no but um
so his reasoning was was that it
kind of sent him into like a downward
spiral of depression
he's like i hate this world yeah because
like he was going out on a limb to help
this person
using his platform to really help
somebody in need and
he was like he had no other agenda in
his heart other than just help
right and here's this guy who turns
around and just basically slanders him
and like throws around falsehoods and
just straight up lies about
and then people automatically believe
him yeah yeah and people just basically
torched his ass right and he started
he he came out and he basically this
podcast is brought to you by purple my
friends
let me tell you something if you put a
bunch of crap on a piece of dookie
is it still a piece of dookie i'm
talking about your bed right now
because you could do the same stuff with
pillows you could put a pillow case over
a piece of crap pillow
but it's still going to hurt that neck
later well that's because you don't have
a purple pillow
or a purple mattress and no not all
mattresses
and pillows are created the same you
know this
ask your spine the purple grid sets
purple mattress
apart from every other mattress is a
patented comfort technology
that instantly adapts to your body's
natural shape and sleep
style we spend so much time sleeping you
have to understand this
i've been sleeping like a freaking king
ever since i've been sleeping on my
purple
mattress it's quite impressive keeps me
nice and cool and helps me sleep
like i have never slept before in my
life experience
the purple grid and you'll sleep like
you never have before go to purple.com
gb10 and use promo code gb10 for a
limited time
you'll get 10 off any order of 200
or more that's purple.com gb10 promo
code gb10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more
terms apply said that he's been
collecting evidence over the past two
years
um to basically make the case damn it
took him that long
i mean i guess it was a combination of
being depressed and not wanting to
you know be out in this guy all you
gotta do is this is my bank account
let money go yeah so so yeah that's what
he showed that's what he's showing now
yeah yeah that
he's coming out with all that stuff and
now he's starting to get the favor of
the people back again because
now i can do magic once again yeah and
he's he's kind of going back to his old
ways but
yeah it just kind of reminded me of that
um but what happened to this homeless
dude he literally smoked it away
um yeah he was he was he had a drug
problem
and so well first of all magic of rahat
why don't you find somebody a little
more deserving than this drug addict
what did you think was gonna happen dude
well you know he he i think i think he
was just uh
being a little bit naive and a little
bit too
optimistic because i know there are
homeless people out there who are out on
their ass because
of you know really bad circumstances
they're out there with their kids and
their family
right maybe you should have found
somebody else who didn't have a crack
rock in your mouth while you were
talking
yeah so like uh i guess kind of the
story behind it is is that the dude kind
of got back
fell back into drug use and needed more
money
and like there's you know accusations of
like
he was holding like outlandish parties
oh 100
yeah just kind of blowing the money not
using it
very responsibly i'm gonna hold this
crack rock in my dick skin
and you gotta smoke that [ __ ] out of it
baby what did you think was gonna happen
people don't know about like the
homeless situation specifically in this
city there's a lot of people that are
homeless
on purpose yeah they like living in
squalor yeah
they want to smoke their [ __ ] they want
to do drugs they want to be out there
and they don't want to follow society's
rules yeah
i mean [ __ ] man la's speaking of that
la's homeless problem is so [ __ ] out
of control you saw a little tokyo right
[ __ ] it's post-apocalyptic as [ __ ] it's
not just little tokyo now though it's
like everywhere
k-town right oh yeah it's spreading out
further
into downtown bro i was driving by city
hall
la city hall right there's a [ __ ]
homeless encamp
just a row and then they just fenced off
right where it gets the city hall so
that they can't get anywhere
near there and it's like bro it's like
on your [ __ ] doorstep now
you know and and like the spread of it
has gotten so out of control that
you literally see homeless encampments
in every part of the city
every part of la you'll see it it it's
like you'll see it in hollywood you're
seating
i wonder what happened because they were
managing it before
so why did they stop managing i don't i
don't i don't think there was
ever really like a tight hold on
managing the problem
you know and and what happened was
during the pandemic a lot of these
businesses had to shut down
or or at least close temporarily and
homeless people were like great let's
just set up camp there now
because we previously couldn't go there
because there's a lot of foot traffic
there
there's you know business happening
there but then nobody's coming through
there anymore
that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna start
getting some duct tape
i'm gonna put cardboard boxes all over
the streets so it's just b-boys doing
windmills
they can't take they can't do [ __ ] bro
is venice speech
along the whole [ __ ] boardwalk dude
just
encampment like that down the whole
street so this is the hard part too
and i don't think people understand how
it it's hard to manage the homeless
situation because a lot of it is by
choice
so it's hard it's hard to say that
because there's definitely a good amount
of people
who ended up there because of you know
mental problems right
once funding ran out for some of these
institutions and facilities
where did they end up being i mean when
i was volunteering they said that was
very true like
four four years ago yeah he goes but now
it's like because i volunteer when i
first moved to la i volunteered at
homeless shelters all the time yeah so
but from what i was being told was like
if these people want to get
food oh they get it they can get food
like we have these facilities here they
can get three square meals a day
yeah yeah they go so when they ask you
for money it's it's for alcohol or drugs
yeah this is like an issue that they've
been dealing with for a very long time
i'm not sure if that's really the case
this is what was told to me while i was
volunteering right
so like for me from what i've seen like
there's definitely people out there who
are homeless because they're homeless
yeah but i think specifically in that
skid row
venice beach area oh there's definitely
a drug problem there's no doubt about it
those pockets i'm not talking about you
know these other areas but specifically
in skid row
venice beach like these high street
traffic metropolitan party areas
they are doing drugs you know oh you see
them do it openly
on the on the [ __ ] street there was
an instance where they created a
synthetic drug that was killing these
[ __ ] it's like
damn [ __ ] like y'all can't get a
job but you know how to create a
synthetic drug the [ __ ] bum king
you know the bum king man he's like i
need to get
i need to get paid that's so funny you
cut that cocaine not on my string you
cut it right over there
next to that garbage can [ __ ]
yes
but it's it's wild man it's [ __ ] wild
um
there's a guy uh on youtube his name is
uh
german in los angeles or something like
that he just basically goes around
documenting the homeless problem in la
just go
travels all around l.a and that's that's
his [ __ ] that's what he does
and it's like even places that i haven't
visited during the pandemic
i see what it was before and what it is
now and i'm like
holy [ __ ] man and you know people might
look at that and think
dude it can't possibly be like oh it's
[ __ ] real out here
man like little tokyo i went to eat
there to go eat at one of my favorite
ramen spots
ramen right went there once i haven't
been back to little tokyo since yeah
because it's bad
yeah it is it just smells like [ __ ] and
piss all over the place it's
it's [ __ ] crazy because it's like a
hop skipping away from some of these
like luxury properties in downtown yeah
i saw
i don't even know what this dude was
doing but this full busted open a fire
hydrant right
he opened up a suitcase and started
collecting water inside the suitcase
i'm like yo what what the [ __ ] am i
looking at
are you gonna take this water bro what
the [ __ ] is gonna happen
right i don't know man la is just a
weird city too i was thinking about this
the other day
and specifically because i was looking
up the uh the whole kim kardashian thing
i look at kim kardashian's face and i'm
like this is the face that set the
standard for what people think beauty is
in
this city specifically right it's kind
of weird now
and i don't even know how to bring up
this conversation because i'm a dude so
i'm not a girl i don't know what this is
what this is what it's like to be a girl
obviously right
but there there has been this weird
shift that i've been seeing online
where previously before it's look you
are
beautiful the way you are like there's
so many things that you should
appreciate about yourself and a lot of
your differences should be celebrated
but now like the rhetoric is well if i
can get surgery on my face who are you
to tell me
i can't get exactly so like what
happened to this
so now what the positivity movement
isn't
you know love yourself because you're
beautiful the way that you are and these
differences should be celebrated yeah
now it's like mind your [ __ ] business
it's respect my choice
yeah if i have if i have the money to
change my face this is my one body i
have one life to live
why can't i change it and i'm like
okay there's that's a valid i guess
that's pretty valid valid too
valid but i i don't necessarily you know
uh agree with that sentiment yeah i had
to sit and think about it too right
because i'm like oh both points are
really valid
i think the only thing that bothers me
about that right when it comes to like
physical beauty right
is the the amount of emphasis that's put
onto it right and what it teaches the
generation after us
yeah right is that the like your looks
are that [ __ ] important
like that's how important it is in your
life and the reason why i say this is
because
tell me why the people who are so that
are the most
pro plastic surgery change your nose
change your face
or excessive amount of makeup or
whatever happens to be in these huge
metropolitan cities but when i go back
to a smaller town which is where i'm
from
that conversation doesn't exist also too
from my personal anecdotal
experience right everybody i know that
has gone through that type of stuff that
is so pro about it
they are constantly just berating people
telling people to do what they do
like oh why you should do this this and
that is completely okay
why why do i have to go through why do
you have to give me this moral
justification to why it's fine because
and what it sounds like is that you want
you want to feel okay with it
unless so you're trying to make other
people feel okay with it right but how
often have we seen
that i believe is a general truth
that when people focus so much on stuff
that's fleeting such as
physical beauty which once again we're
all going to get older absolutely man
right
absolutely and when you put an emphasis
on that so much what does that do to you
mentally
right where does that put your value on
as a person as a human being which by
the way
like a lot of men have a responsibility
in this as well because some of the
dudes out there say some of the dumbest
[ __ ] they go
i don't like it when girls wear makeup
that's funny because you're the one
that's jacking off these girls on
instagram
so you kind of set that standard for
what beauty is yeah right what an
attractive woman is
because i hear a lot of dudes that go i
don't get why these girls you know
inject their [ __ ] big ass lips or
whatever right
like it looks so stupid i agree i think
they don't look human at all yeah but
you're the one following them yeah
you're the one liking their photos so
you're sending a mixed message too so
it's just a weird situation man
it i mean but that's that's kind of like
the status quo now right and and a lot
of that is to blame is
it you know advent of social media
i mean like you see
kind of this definition of beauty this
culturally defined
definition of beauty and this is
society's
definition of beauty and you take that
and then you just spread it around
everywhere and then all of a sudden it's
just like
everybody kind of looks like that talks
like that acts like that
and and it's like two
kim yay's testament like to like their
what they've done the influence
that they've had they've had a huge
influence oh for sure the epitome of a
power couple
right both of their influence on culture
um both of their
influence on like uh kind of turning
their brand into a business
right i mean that's they were definitely
the epitome of
a power couple for better or worse you
know
they're that you definitely see a lot of
negative effects of that too
and at the end of the day it really
comes down to
you as an individual like you just kind
of have to be aware
of like what's out there and really be
able to think for yourself
on that whatever that topic is like
let's say about beauty
right if you're a girl looking at all
these um
instagram accounts of like people you
follow
that look a certain way you know you
don't have to necessarily
judge yourself by mirroring yourself to
them that's
them you know you're not ever gonna beat
them
and so you don't have to worry about oh
i don't look that way
so i must not be attractive easier said
than done
obviously because when you're constantly
being shoved down your throat
this idea of this is what beauty is this
is what beauty is then you're just
reminded of
i'm not that though and i'm not that and
i'm not ever gonna be that unless i do
something about it
and so it really exploits your
insecurities um
but yeah i think it's hard i think it's
specifically hard because i said like
these dudes
they talk a big game you know i like
girls who don't really wear makeup
uh i don't like these girls who are
faking plastic but that's the girl that
you're following on instagram and social
media
right so it's like yo your actions don't
speak the same as your words so mind you
if the girl
who is quote unquote naturally pretty
right has nothing done to her she just
looks like an average girl she's very
cute yeah had the same amount of
attention and love
and that was respected for her other
attributes her skills in her mind
then maybe this conversation would be a
little bit different and once again too
like we're all
we're all we're all animals right so
obviously we're physically attracted to
the things that we're physically
attracted to
right but when we say things like
the type of girl that i like is this but
then your actions don't speak and
they're the exact opposite
and then you get upset at the opposite
gender for doing stuff
that they think is going to attract you
because that's what your behavior shows
who are you to get angry at them or or
even have an opinion on it yeah and i
think that's the part that gets really
confusing for me
i just i think that i i don't know like
i don't know where that conversation
shift happened
like it's it happened with kim k and
then her uh her younger sister uh
the one that doesn't even look like
herself at all anymore um
kylie kylie yeah that girl i don't know
who the [ __ ] that is i saw a previous
picture of her i was like
yo i mean obviously she got worked on i
mean she denies it but it's
denies it yeah she doesn't even look
like the same they're like
have you ever heard of makeup [ __ ] i
know what makeup is
that's not just makeup you look like a
different human being
you went from typical thin lip white
girl yeah to
saudi arabian princess you don't even
look like the same ethnicity
yeah yeah for sure and and it's like
when you look at that
this podcast is brought to you by excuse
[ __ ] okay i'm not gonna do this this
podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends if you haven't
heard of skillshare are you living under
a rock
and by yourself without any skills to
share see what i did there listen
if you are a person out there that is
trying to gain some new skills in your
life but you don't know where to start
and you are suppressing your creativity
well with skillshare you can find
inspiration in the moment and learn how
to express
all of that with the great and amazing
list of courses
that you can learn from if you are like
me you hate having to search
for credible people to teach you things
that you want to learn on your free time
and i'm talking about skills that you
can learn for a side hustle
uh things that you always wanted to do
just for fun and this is something
outside of just traditional learning in
a classroom these are courses that you
have at your fingertips whenever you
want based on your
schedule and they really just get to the
point listen i'm actually taking a class
right now
that's teaching me how to uplift my
space with plants because i don't know
how to decorate my place
with any plants and a lot of you might
think like why would you need to know
that but you don't think about these
things well skillshare even has courses
on that
and has helped me uplift my space to the
max
listen my friends explore your
creativity at skillshare.combrain and
get a free trial of premium membership
that's skillshare.com
brain bring color and beauty and fun to
your year
don't wait to accomplish the things that
you want to do this
year because you don't know where to
start remember that's skillshare.com
brain it's hard it's it's really hard to
to separate that and be like yeah
they're um
pretty or or handsome or whatever in
their own right and that's
them and they're celebrities and and you
know
it's their job to always look glamorous
or fabulous or whatever because they
have a platform
they have sponsorships you know they got
brand deals whatever
and so they have to carry themselves and
present themselves in a certain way
but it's like that's not you though dude
have you seen
um like the girls who'd get like the
huge lip injections yeah it's [ __ ]
disgusting when they don't wear uh
lipstick with it it looks [ __ ] nuts
it looks like somebody sucked their face
yeah it looks like they got stung by a
bee yeah you know
literally somebody went to town on their
faces it's such a stupid [ __ ] look
i i like i honestly think it's it looks
ridiculous odd yeah it's ridic but
that's what's culturally beautiful right
now
like in in in this pop culture world and
i'll look at before and afters
of certain people that i know right and
i'm like you already had
beautiful big lips and you went bigger
yeah you went extra
how the [ __ ] what were you thinking like
why what
who told you in your head or what did
you see or what was fed to you that said
that what you had wasn't good enough
yeah and that this here was better
yeah that's the part where i'm confused
well see that's that's the part where
the disconnect happens because like
we cannot place ourselves in their mind
and know their thoughts right obviously
there
is a sense of insecurity enough for it
to drive that
type of action and decision but the
thing is it's like at the end of the day
you you got you got to be able to
to be able to separate that and be able
to love yourself
like you said looks are fleeting
everybody's gonna get old and saggy
and then we're just gonna be [ __ ]
dirt in the ground at some point
like this this very
short and temporary period of time
where where actually you know i take
that back because they could
keep getting [ __ ] work done into
their 50s into their 60s into their 70s
to try to maintain
and then all of a sudden you just become
like what are you anymore
you know it's the weirdest thing when
the most and and i want to see somebody
who
is the opposite right when i see like i
mean
it exists and once again i'm saying it
from the small group amount of people
that i've ever been around
[Music]
every person that has maybe i had a
conversation with that was a girl that
you know had a lot of stuff done and i'm
not attacking i'm just
just genuinely curious right and i know
these people and they know it too
they always have like the most they have
the biggest issues with self-esteem
and how they how they look sure because
nothing is ever enough
right so when they because what'll
happen is it's like listen oh i just
wanted to get this done
and then a year later i see them later i
was like oh i wanted to get this done
yeah i wanted to get
and then it's just it's a snowball
becomes an addiction yeah and i'm like
what happened to just the one thing that
you said that that's all you ever needed
but then because that's that's the
gateway like a drug you know whatever
yeah once you once you get that done
you've already crossed over now
yeah people already got this done i mean
yeah i would like to
you know try this too so once again
these are just thoughts it's not really
a hardcore opinion because once again
i'm a dude so i don't
i don't know what the [ __ ] goes on in
the girl's head look i think
we're entitled to our opinion too i mean
it's it's not like we're
uh psychologists here trying to like
diagnose a problem right yeah we're just
we're observing and we're commenting on
it right
and i think we have a similar
observation in that sense i look at that
and i'm like
that that's so [ __ ] terrible that is
so terrible especially for the psyche of
like these teenager girls
right to just constantly be bombarded
with like this imagery and definition of
beauty that they do not have
that will be humanly unattainable in
most cases
the only way to get it is through
surgery measures
and so like you're you're planting this
idea in their head
of like inferiority like you are not
pretty you are not beautiful unless you
get this yeah unless you look like this
and the only way you're gonna get that
unfortunately because of
your genes is through this through this
route because it also reminds me of the
same thing that uh
when i see people try to replace their
value
based on the cool things that they buy
with their money right like
for example when it comes to clothing
right some people will wear
that that kanye west white t-shirt right
but to the layman's eye it's just the
white t-shirt
so you go out and you let people know
yeah this is a kanye west t-shirt
exactly
because you want to say to somebody like
yo i'm better than you yeah like i got
this
it's a status symbol right you wanna you
wanna
appear as if
you're you know of a certain status
maybe maybe not of a status that you
actually are
but but having that on and you know what
to each their own with how they want to
spend their money that's completely up
to them
but i think that the real
cancer of of like the situation within
pop culture and society
is the idolization of these celebrities
that's the cancer because that's where
all of this [ __ ] stems from
yes historically ever since hollywood
has been created
the whole idea of creating a celebrity
has been
to sell right you're selling something
you're selling an image you're selling a
movie you're selling a tv show
you're selling a product and in order to
do that you have to you have to do
certain things
but back then versus now
media hasn't been the same or media
wasn't the same as it was back then as
it is now
now it's like in your face like inches
away from your face
constant non-stop being reminded over
and over again
yeah pretty uh you know pretty and
handsome celebrities have existed for
for decades
always just the difference now is how
much
frequent it is yeah how frequently
people consume what it is that they do
in their lifestyle
and and feel inferior to that and i
always tell people
um i always say that i always tell
people but i really do it's that
there's it's gotten to the point now
where people feel like
they need social media it's like listen
if you work a job and you're living your
life
and it doesn't require you to have it
you don't need it
where did this happen where it says that
you need social media who says that
you do not i need it it's a part of my
job right right i
need it you don't like you actually
don't
need it yeah so when they say like oh
this stuff is being shoved in my face
you are also participating in it though
nobody says you have to be
on instagram all the time especially
when it's not your job
why why while we're on this topic why
don't we
uh present a challenge to the watchers
your viewers
right try not using instagram unless
you're watching my page
yeah after you watch this
after you watch no but but it doesn't
have to be
like i mean sure it would be ideal to do
like a detox of social media in general
but let's say the one that you use the
most which for most people
i'm guessing is instagram or twitter
right okay pornhub
you know whatever social media outlet is
used just try for a week
just try for a week not to use it and i
promise you maybe like in the first like
day or two or three you're gonna be
jonesing and you're gonna be like [ __ ] i
need to get on it
but then once you kind of get over that
hump how
much it will simplify your life and just
like make you feel
uh a little bit more at peace i'll tell
you this guys right
i mean people know they follow me like
up until maybe like a month ago i
rarely posted you know like it's it's
just
it's not that i don't i like instagram i
think there's a lot of fun stuff it was
just hard for me to be on the platform
when the platform became uh
a marketplace right where they were just
selling me stuff
all the time yeah it started becoming
really obnoxious and then i started
seeing people's posts change where
they're i started seeing less of
people's personality and it started
becoming more and more like youtube
where everybody's content was exactly
the same and it's weird when i see
people
who aren't even in the space right
trying to
try to sell me stuff check it out yo
check out hey yo i'm about to do a ig
live yeah
who loser to who to who what are they
talking about right now
you know so when the platform started
changing a little bit like i started
liking the platform less not from a
moralistic standpoint it just became
really boring
you know and so it was hard for me to
post and um i think i started getting
sucked up into
uh you know what like i'm not going to
have a really dope photo so i'm not
going to post and then i thought to
myself i'm like
what did i have an instagram for in the
first place it was just to do dumb [ __ ]
yeah so now i just do dumb [ __ ] again
and it started becoming
a little more fun yeah you know yeah no
for me um
instagram i mean i've talked about this
with you before on the podcast
but it it's it was always more of like
an extension
of like my my um
branding yeah yeah speak right and so
like when i was doing music even for
like secret society stuff it it serves
as a platform to build awareness for it
but for me personally like because i
enjoyed
uh taking photo or taking photos it was
just a hobby of mine so
i i like to take photos and post it up
um
and it you know whether i get one like
on it or 300 likes on it or five
that really doesn't matter i just did it
for fun but then
it got to the point where i found myself
like on having to like constantly post
without even thinking about it and i'm
just like what am i doing
and so now for me honestly it's like
most of the
accounts of people that i don't know
that i follow are
are things that i look for inspiration
so i don't really use
instagram anymore but when i do pop into
it i just look i follow like
artists or like you know these outlets
that that you're using your instagram
on a personal scale yeah yeah which is
how it should be
it's a personal thing yeah you know and
that's how it originally started and in
fact
i remember instagram's main thing was
for you it was for people to stay in
touch
with friends through pictures like
facebook does except without words is
with pictures instead so it's a way for
you to connect with people
that uh you don't see often but you know
what the problem is is that
anytime you're able to monetize
something it just changes the play it
changes the game
yeah 100 you know and like i said i i
don't
obviously you know social media is a
huge part of my life like i don't want
to
demonize it like that but i want people
to understand that you have a choice to
partake in it or not
you have to be very now you have to be
more so than ever
very conscious of the stuff that's being
fed to you yeah right yeah and it's
happening without you knowing yeah
so if you are conscious of it then you
can control it a little bit for sure
for sure and i don't even think it has
to be an extreme of you partaking it or
not
even if you partake how you partake in
it it's very important right yeah
um and and and that's that's really the
point to drive home is
is like if you're using these platforms
nothing wrong with it but just be
aware of of like what the intention is
of these brands or these celebrities
like what are they trying to achieve by
posting what they post
uh promoting what they promote talking
about what they talk about
usually if you connect the dots there's
a dollar
tied to the end of it yeah and because
that's the case they're trying to
manipulate you in some way
i mean that's that's essentially what
marketing is right yeah
um listen i've i've been looking to buy
like an electric bike right i have one
right now it's but it's an electric road
bike it's mainly for my commute stuff
yeah but i want that one that goes like
40 miles an hour
60 miles per hour and that [ __ ] right
there is like five grand i know
and i looked up one and then i have like
80 ads for electric bikes
for sure i almost bought one yesterday i
was like your boy ain't got the money
like that yo you want me to tell you
some trippy ass [ __ ] remember
um when me you khalif and ray
we briefly talked about clifford the red
dog
yeah real [ __ ] bro that night i went
home
and i opened up youtube on my tv that
one of the first suggestions i got was
the trailer for clifford the red dog
movie
isn't that crazy i'm like yo there is no
point in my [ __ ] history of searches
or whatever
i've ever looked at yes but all of a
sudden i get a suggestion for the
[ __ ] trailer for clifford
and it just so happens that there's a
movie coming out that's crazy
i was like all right man i could chalk
that up as coincidence but i think
that's pretty ridiculous
you know penis size penis size penis
size penis size penis size penis size
i'm going to add this says do you think
your dick is too small exactly there's a
ruler next to a [ __ ] a human diagram
of a duck
that's nuts though man yeah everything
is so integrated i think that's why
now more than ever we're seeing a lot of
people unplug and go to these airbnbs
because of how connected we are to our
our technology yeah like when i wake up
the first thing i do in the morning is
look at my phone and i'm like what am i
doing dude yeah yeah
why am i doing this yeah that's why i
like biking so much lately like even
when i bike i don't even have headphones
on
i just bike just enjoy the the peace and
the scenery
right exactly i bike i hear the wind and
that's really about it yeah occasionally
if i want to listen to like a playlist
or music or if i'm really into
some kind of uh some new artist yeah
i'll put on some music but even when i
drive now i don't even have music on
sometimes
yeah well i mean truth be told not like
you can do anything else much these days
that's true
that's all you really got right yeah i'm
gonna go ride my bike
i know all i've been doing is riding my
bike everywhere today was actually the
first time i actually put gas in my car
in three weeks oh wow
yeah it's been a long time actually you
know what that's kind of been the
average for me too
like once every three weeks because i
i'm not [ __ ] going anywhere
it's covered baby i'm just at home man
i'm [ __ ]
chilling you know working playing games
on my free time
i mean social media did one good thing i
mean i don't know if it's a good thing
because a part of it was because of
cancer culture but there's a lot of
stuff that people can't get away with
right and we're going to talk about this
thing that
happened like a couple weeks ago which
you'd even know about but it was
uh there was this company of uh is this
company in texas
i think it was about three it was three
women who decided that they wanted to
rebrand mahjong because it needed a
facelift right
we're talking about something here
that's very culturally important
to asian people mahjong it's a it's a
very very old game and
there has been a lot of other iterations
i think like gin rummy or something like
that
there's an american version of it as
well right yeah but
it's this weird weird feeling and you
know when i looked at it
i i personally don't want to flip out
every time somebody does something
culturally insensitive right
because it's [ __ ] exhausting i get
tired i get tired of [ __ ]
right yeah and so sometimes i gotta
check myself i'm like are you just being
irritated just to be irritated
but the more and more i look at this i'm
like who do you [ __ ] think you are
you know exactly that's the exact
question that
who the [ __ ] do you think you are yeah
to
who the [ __ ] appointed you to to say
you know what this game needs a [ __ ]
refresh
this game that millions of people if not
billions of people enjoy in its
current iteration the current iteration
has been the same for
hundreds of years these symbols they
need to refresh a more modern refresh
[ __ ] there's a language on that [ __ ]
what are you talking about right now
and like who the [ __ ] is your pr person
that was sitting there saying like
you know what janine this is a good idea
that's a fantastic idea
fire this woman yeah or guy whoever the
[ __ ] those chinks
they don't know what they're doing their
eyes are too small to be able to even
see
and the audacity is that they were
trying to sell it for like 500 400
sets for something that typically cost
30 or 40 dollars that's [ __ ] crazy
man and what asian person didn't think
about this before you [ __ ]
selling they're they're too busy [ __ ]
placing the bets in the casinos
the way that it already is man like
that's thinking about changing the game
up i remember my grandpa playing mahjong
with his friends
what's it called in korean i don't know
what it's called in korean um
i don't know i don't know i can't
remember the [ __ ] name but my grandpa
used to play that [ __ ]
you know all the time with this with his
[ __ ] old ass little grinkly ass
friends
yeah so like i just remember
so when i hear this stuff that's very
culturally important like pan-asian like
very culturally important to us right
it's something that we really really
enjoy
that's like somebody coming up to me and
telling me like you know somebody takes
like you noti like we play that yeah
it's like a new year's game yeah you
know what
this isn't dope enough and you know and
all of a sudden white people are like
have you heard
of you nori you know and they rebranded
they sell these little wooden sticks
and this is something that we do every
new year's yeah right that's culturally
important to what signifies
it's it's it's personal right and then
you take that
and you want to profit off of it because
what you put in your words is that
it's not good enough the way it was yeah
but now that we've touched it yeah
by now these americans actually exactly
that that's the part that
is the most irritating about it is like
you have no connection
to this yeah it's it like it's it has
you have no connection to like the
cultural importance of it
or or just like the history of it and
all of a sudden
you just decide you're gonna make make a
[ __ ] bold decision and say you know
what
this [ __ ] is whacked away it's basically
what they're saying yeah
and and on top of that we're gonna
[ __ ] charge you 500
for this and make money off of it it's
like the audacity man the audacity of
some of these [ __ ] people
it's it's it's mind-blowing but like you
said you can't let
this [ __ ] bother you too much because
there's too much of it there's too much
of it going on and it's like
if if if if you let it uh like bother
you on a deep level
whenever you you hear about the [ __ ] or
see the box just read about this [ __ ]
it's
you're just not gonna have a happy life
man so check this out so
it goes when the sets released the
marketing copy on the mahjong line's
website was
which has been taken down touted them as
being modern and fun as opposed to
traditional mahjong that tiles that were
all the same
it's like what were you thinking when
you put that out when you said that
yeah how the [ __ ] were people not going
to feel like they were being dissed look
look at
what you've you're saying traditional
yeah
traditional that's a key word there
there's tradition behind that
you don't just [ __ ] say i'm going to
change tradition because i feel
like it because i feel like i know more
than all the other people who partake in
this game
and i think it's wack yeah the sets
range from
325 to 400 how did they justify that
what's their reason
i don't what do they say like they use
some premium like tiles or something or
like
i mean what what is the reasoning for
that that should better be made out of
some [ __ ] rare elephant tusk
right better there has to be something i
mean if they're going to
try to justify charging that much they
have to like
point out something of why it's such a
premium set it can't just be on the idea
of
we revamped the game to how we see fit
that the way we think is better that
can't just be the selling point
it's it's just so weird right and
like i said i'm always trying to think
about you know yo david are you [ __ ]
tripping
you know but when i look at the design
it starts to irritate me
you know and like this is the modern
representation of what it is
you know it looks like scribble scrabble
that you see on a five-year-old white
girl's wall
you know and this is supposed to be the
modernized fun version i cannot believe
they're trying to charge
[ __ ] a few hundred bucks for that
[ __ ] man that's
isn't that crazy that's out of control
425 dollars for that [ __ ] yeah so what
happened like you said they took it down
so like they take it down
i wonder i think they had to do a public
apology they took it down because this
was a huge
rightfully so man you know rightfully so
there's going to be people out there who
aren't a part of this culture that
that are going to say well is in america
a mixing of all these cultures there's a
lot of reiterations
yeah but there's some things that are so
culturally deep that you just don't [ __ ]
with right and this was one of those
things
well no i mean yeah america is
is definitely like a mix of cultures and
like a you know huge melting pot of
different people different uh
from different countries but they
there's still
preservation of culture and tradition
within like
you know their background and so like to
say
yeah we're just gonna take some i i
don't i mean i just think it's
ridiculous that
the the audacity is what what uh the
audacity is the thing dude that [ __ ]
yeah that's the part that [ __ ]
bothers me man
yeah again the question that pops up in
your head is who the [ __ ] do you think
you
are who the [ __ ] do you think you are uh
this is like some of their descriptions
that they put on it they go some have
asked
what is the real mahjong well all the
met well all the madness of mahjong
began in china hundreds of years ago so
they own
that distinction fair and square when an
american businessman named joseph
babak babic babcock returned
from working overseas in china he
brought the game with him in the 1920s
it became a national craze upon the
publication of babcock's book
rules for mahjong the red book of rules
over the
over time the game evolved from the
original chinese version to be
distinctly american
with the addition of jokers to the game
like it's even that description
sounds like a diss you know what i mean
they go
and specifically in this type of
rhetoric and you could tell whoever
wrote this stuff
is already irritated just by how they
wrote it like i'm sick and tired it
sounds like i'm sick and tired of people
saying that this is just for chinese
people yeah that's how it sounds like
when you're writing this
yeah and it's not even like it was done
on accident this person who wrote this
is clearly irritated that people think
that it's only a chinese thing
even though it was re it's a reiteration
that's been done in america
it's already seen in the rhetoric so you
guys couldn't even put your emotions
behind when you wrote this [ __ ]
to the point where you had to sneak this
in a little bit yeah there's like
problems like that you have a business
what the [ __ ] were you thinking
you know what i mean and like this is
the part that bothers me too he goes
uh oh
this part right here uh well all of the
madness of mahjong began in chinese
uh in china hundred hundreds of years
ago so they own that distinction
fair and square barons what the [ __ ]
does that mean
yeah you might as well have just called
them chinks
like yeah those chinks made the game
fair and square fair square fine
whatever yeah but yeah
we think them slant-eyed [ __ ]
yeah
did not know what they're looking at and
and the game was was not fun
the way it was it was just so stupid
like i just want to meet the people who
were behind this thinking that this was
a good
idea and i think like the problem is is
that
man i and i hate always like talking
about ray [ __ ] all the time but it's
something that's kind of important
because i want people to get it that
the reason why some of this stuff
becomes like
[ __ ] up it's like i talk about it
here's a great example um we talk about
this in these lunchbox stories right
where back in the day it may not be like
this now in like california or a lot of
progressive cities
where uh people usually get made fun of
for eating their cultural foods that's
embarrassing
it was an embarrassing [ __ ] i was i was
so [ __ ] ashamed like yeah you know i
tell my mom hey don't ever pack me this
[ __ ] again
yeah like everybody was like what's this
smell like oh that's nasty
i was like just pack me a sandwich like
every other kid is [ __ ] getting you
know you know
you know our parents are making this
bomb ass [ __ ] yeah exactly
i want the craft singles yeah i want
that wonder bread
and that gummy cheese [ __ ] mystery
meat you know you better give me that
disgusting [ __ ] right now
because i want to fit in i mean i was a
little different like i remember my
parents would tell me not to take korean
food
but i'm like one of those [ __ ] that
never gave a [ __ ] so i'm like no i'm
gonna take the kimchi fried rice
and my mom's like no you're not taking
it i'm like no i'm gonna take it no i
mean like
when you're in elementary though like
first second grade right it's hard it's
rough bro cause like that's when
it's a moment where you recognize you're
different
you know you might have felt like oh
it's all good
and then you bring out something like
food that's so tight it's closely tied
to culture
and then it's like whoa that shit's
[ __ ] nasty yeah bro what the [ __ ] is
that
dude i remember um one of these kids
brought
chow mein to school right and this kid
kept on making fun of him saying he was
eating
worms you know what i mean like and i
just never i'm like [ __ ] you ate
chinese food [ __ ] eat noodles who the
[ __ ] doesn't eat noodles
yeah you know what i mean that's what
i'm saying it's like you're over here
eating [ __ ] ragu spaghetti huh yeah
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i don't understand if it was like kimchi
or some [ __ ] you know
like some something okay
that's even korean
yeah that's that's definitely a smaller
you know group of people who like that
[ __ ] but it's
noodles you know what i mean yeah that
was the weird thing too and i think
just to tie back to what i was saying is
like the reason why this becomes
something where it becomes a little
personal it's like
yo you used to make fun of me for this
[ __ ] you actually belittled me because i
like my cultural food but now that you
eat it
suddenly is socially acceptable but but
let me tell you
that you made it fair and square but
we're gonna
we made it better yeah you know fair and
sweet yeah
so so yeah i mean don't you think that
yeah we should feel a certain way about
that [ __ ]
yeah bully some of these kids like you
made fun of them you made them feel
ashamed of their culture you try to
strip their culture away
but now that you say it's cool yeah the
way you did it yeah yeah
and now you're mad at us for telling you
like yo what the [ __ ] is going on and
now we're the [ __ ] so it's a
lose-lose situation for us for sure
and that's the only perspective that i
want people to understand
and that's why you have to be a little
culturalist because there's a history of
of people ridiculing people
for for loving their culture like we had
to conform to what you did yeah maybe
not so much for me but i understand it
from other people's perspective where it
was even more extreme than i had when i
was a kid and
not even necessarily a thing of loving
your culture like when you're that
young that's just what it is that's your
life that's what you're born into
yeah i eat rice every [ __ ] meal at
home
there's nothing unusual about it until
you're exposed to oh
actually you know other people don't eat
this stuff
and they're telling me that what i eat
and what i like is actually gross
what the [ __ ] is going on here yeah and
it's it's like confusing when you're
that young
trying to kind of reconcile like that
that disconnect
right you know what's interesting
actually recently you know the uh that
that one grammy winning christian rapper
what's his name
oh uh craig lecrae lecrae yeah
the created a video that i think kind of
started
uh i mean it's not it's not huge right
mind you i [ __ ] with the craig i think
he's a really good dude yeah
right but even with people of color
there's sometimes a cultural mishap that
happens
so there's a video that lecrae put out
where he was um
he was eating uh he goes i've never
eaten sushi before i don't like it him
and his buddy
don't like sushi or whatever and they're
literally gagging as they're eating
sushi on this video
and some people are writing in the
comments and that aren't asian yeah like
yo people can like the food that they
like
i'm like but at the same time like once
again
we are deleting the the negative [ __ ]
that asian people got for enjoying that
their food yeah so when they see
somebody especially in a time like this
now
that are not open to trying this food
because it's different but you're
literally
gagging and throwing up right that's
just it's culturally insensitive so for
sure
so it's not just a white person thing
it's something that's been happening in
america for quite a while when it comes
to our cuisine right yeah which is why
you know in order to sell some of this
food it had to be hyper americanized
this is why you have
general sews chicken this is what which
by the way i love
you know panda express which i love you
know you know slippery shrimp baby yeah
oh yeah don't even get me started on
this slippery
extra slippery shrimp bro you know and
this is from a good guy who i [ __ ] with
heavy makes dope christian rap which a
lot of i hate a lot of christian rappers
she's actually pretty dope
you know and even him who is a person of
color makes that mishap
you know this is it happens all the time
yeah that that's definitely
a poor judgment on his part you know for
sure
to not recognize how that could come
across culturally and sensitive
it's it look doesn't mean you have to
[ __ ] enjoy
you know other foods from other cultures
yeah it's you
completely in your right to not enjoy it
but don't [ __ ] post something that
paints it in such a negative light
yeah like this thing is so gross and i
don't like it so much
i [ __ ] gag even with smelling it or
eat tasting it and i'm gonna show you
like that's not necessary if you just
say i don't like sushi
okay we move on yeah and you're doing a
whole video about it yeah and also
you're a grammy award-winning [ __ ]
artist yeah that's
that's what people don't understand
right they go well he's just a per
but he's a person now with a huge
[ __ ]
platform that is the difference right
because i've made that excuse before too
like i'm just a regular person but
i still have to move smart because i
have one point whatever four
or two or 1.1 million followers on this
on this youtube page yeah i have 500k on
instagram
if i go around just saying [ __ ]
barbershop talk like it's normal like
it's all good like we're just talking
around a bunch of homies yeah
all the time which i do a lot but i'm
still smart about my [ __ ]
you know not everything is painted black
and white and everybody keeps putting
these black and white rules
as if these people who are in the public
light function with the same type of
stuff that you function with it's not
they have bigger platforms yeah their
reach is way bigger so they have to be a
little smart about it
i mean they're look man i i it always
bothered me
when you know people with big platforms
celebrities
would always be like yeah i don't have
any sense of responsibility you know
to be a role model or to you know be
responsible to like my fa
it's like come on man like it comes with
the territory though
like okay you don't maybe you don't have
to be a hundred percent about that
but you gotta be a preacher yeah but you
gotta have some sense of like
you're influencing people especially
younger people
like who are looking at what you're
doing and and like
really consuming your behavior
your habits your your um
tendencies your lifestyle
they're ha it's not saying oh you know
you have to like change your life and
then it needs to be like this perfect
um you know cookie cutter type of thing
no it just means
be a little bit more responsible is all
you know what i mean yeah
that that's all it is just have a sense
of responsibility yeah like nobody's
nobody's putting the whole culture on
your back right like yo just
you know be smart about your moves a
little bit when you're when you're
performing to
like millions and millions of people
right yeah because
yeah there's a there's a younger
audience out there that's going to
absorb this [ __ ]
you know jokes here and there whatever
that's fine but when people are upset
about this who
are of that culture and we'll wrap that
back to a previous podcast where i was
talking about
just how like you know for us and and
the n word which is a word that we grew
up with
we don't have a say in like how that
makes you feel you also don't have a say
in how that makes us feel when you bash
our food in
on a public platform right it works the
same [ __ ] way
yeah you know and once again i gotta say
this he's not a bad dude yeah it's just
a misstep
yeah you know and i think i just read
the comments when i read that stuff
and people are telling us that we're
tripping about stuff that affects us
culturally
it's like yo aren't you a bunch of
[ __ ] hypocrites
you know and nobody and nobody in the
comments was like mad at lecrae they're
just like
i'm just a little disappointed that's
all they said yeah it's like
i think rightfully so yeah like it's
just it's just more of like
you know cause i'm i'm uh
giving him the benefit of the doubt it
probably wasn't like
uh ill-intentioned oh 100 it wasn't
right hundred percent there was no ill
intention but but but
it's like you know if you have a moment
to reflect now because of
certain reactions from people i don't
think it's hard to make that connection
and understand
i see i see why like you know some
people might have
been offended by this or kind of take it
a ticket the wrong way
and then just offer a quick apology for
it you know yeah
that wasn't my you know my intention all
i was really trying to prove was that i
don't like the food
maybe i went too far to prove that point
and make that point to the point that
it crossed the line yeah he was making
jokes yeah it was fun and whatever like
like i said
if you did that in front of me like away
from screen
and i knew you personally yeah i'm 100 i
wouldn't be offended i'm like yeah it's
full done like sushi
yeah you know whatever that is what it
is right but
you know the platform wasn't right well
here's the thing he already knew he
didn't like sushi he already knew and he
decided to do the video yeah he's
decided to do the video
like nobody needs to see you have a
[ __ ] gag reflex
because of a food you don't like yeah
nobody nobody needs to see that [ __ ]
you're just saying it is enough
like oh i don't like it so much it you
know it makes me i'm [ __ ] even just
saying it might kind of
come across a little bit offensive too
but
you're just saying i don't like it done
you got your point across
no one's gonna attack you because you
don't like it
that's it but yeah he's trying to do a
fun video he's trying to get views and
stuff he's like okay
that's what it is man the [ __ ] that's
what i'm saying this
culture man about the [ __ ] views
about the [ __ ] likes about the
retweets like
it's such a [ __ ] drug man like oh
it's like oh that's a great
it is a drug yeah it gets the dopamine
going in their [ __ ] brains
you know you know what's crazy about
youtube like i i only noticed it
recently i don't know why i just noticed
it now
but when you let's say like i put up a
podcast right and
the podcast is better on views than it
normally does you know what happens on
youtube
they go they show you the stats right
when you look into your page
and they put up these explosions and
streamers they go
hey your your video is performing better
than it normally does
here's the reasons why try this again
and if it does bad they go hey it's not
performing that great what's going on
yeah like they
literally make it a game they chastise
you yeah for
not getting the amount of views that
they normally get rather than people
just allowing people to be on the
platform yeah
now google and youtube are they're
sadistic as [ __ ]
they are giving you these endorphins of
like positive reinforcement for getting
more views
no matter what it is for it doesn't
matter they just go look at the stats
you're doing great
and when you're not doing that great
they'll go oh what's wrong what's the
problem
it's like dude this this platform is
kind of getting crazy yeah i mean
like i'm sure for you when you started
out
when you started out and now like did
the [ __ ] night and day difference
between
what it was and what there was none of
this like it was just
you just did stuff on your own and i
still remember the day when click bait
started happening right
and i was like oh this is kind of fun
but the difference my clickbait actually
there was stuff
that i clickbaited with that was in the
video which i thought that's what it was
but clickbait is literally you
say something and then it's not in the
video at all yeah you know
it's just yeah you're just kind of
fooling them it's like i can't believe
my boob slipped out right
and in the video it's like you'll be in
like you're swimming
yeah and all of a sudden like you come
up from the water and you say
oh my boob could have slipped out and
that's what happened
yeah you know so there's definitely
you know when like we said before when
money comes involved it starts changing
you
i think it starts changing your humanity
a little bit as a person money taints
everything bro like that's what i was
saying in the other podcast too is is
right you you look at what's at the end
of all these things that have been
tainted and just convoluted it's always
money that's what it is man
and it's like as long as there's money
attached to it people are gonna figure
out ways
to to like exploit it uh to make you
uh want it more or like to pay attention
to it more
it's just the nature of living in a
capitalistic society
you know is the end goal is always to
make money
and as much of it as possible it even
[ __ ] up the christian rapper dude
satan satan went in your soul yeah
that's a i'm kind of surprised that
lecrae
i was a little shocked too i was like
yeah he knows better than this
especially for him i'm like
dude you're you're a black dude you know
what's up what it's like to be
you know when it comes to like
culturally exactly sensitive [ __ ] like
exactly
you should know what's up yeah but i
think this is why a lot of like young
asian people are like kind of saying
you know why the [ __ ] is it that we
always we don't get a pass on any of
this [ __ ] yeah you know why the [ __ ] is
it every time that we spay we say our
stuff
we're being overly sensitive that's
always been the case though right
asian people is like asian people have
kind of always been
a you know group of minorities to kind
of get [ __ ] on and and not really have
um an advocate or like a big voice
who kind of speaks for the asian
community
um and it's just more recently in the
past
several years where we started to get a
little bit more
equal representation i guess in
mainstream media
but you know people speaking up about it
yeah which i didn't even realize
too uh you know i've been on this
platform now for what 11 12 years now
like 12 years this year hitting in march
right
and so you know when i was saying some
[ __ ] you know doing these videos just
talking about
i wasn't even trying to direct stuff
about asian culture it was just more me
saying stuff
right and it blew it was blowing people
like these young kids minds
they were like yo who is this asian guy
that he's saying stuff that i want to
say
yeah in my mind i'm like why aren't you
saying it no that's a good point that's
really
because yeah that that um that girl that
ucla girl what was her name
uh alexander wallace okay yeah she
definitely
triggered a lot of people by saying what
she said
and and like you just said a lot of
people had the same thoughts
but then your timing on that was
obviously
perfect because not too many people were
speaking publicly
about it especially having a yellow skin
yeah
right and then you come in and then you
basically going off on a tirade just you
know destroying her
um and that resonated with people
because again there was we didn't have
an advocate
we didn't have somebody who was
basically fighting
and speaking on your behalf or on the
behalf of this community
every like you said everybody thought it
everybody felt it
everybody talked about it but nobody
went out there saying
yo this [ __ ] is [ __ ] terrible and
i'll tell you why
yeah um it was weird you know and it's
funny too because not too long ago when
um
a lot of the stuff was happening to
asian people right uh specifically
because
of you know the kung flu and those type
of comments and
uh you know i guess i didn't say
something fast enough and you know this
one
young girl who's like in her tag she
goes asian advocate
and she wrote this whole paragraph on my
instagram about
you know you influencers out here never
speak up for us asian people and
starting almost like
do you know who the [ __ ] you're talking
to right now i was like
do you know who the [ __ ] you're talking
to right now
that's like kind of this sense of like
entitlement
right i was so that's one thing that
like most comments will never piss me
off but that pissed me off because i
wrote back and i wrote back this whole
and she deleted her comment fast
because i don't think she knew who i was
i think because i lost a lot of weight
yeah you know
and i wrote i was like do you know who i
literally do you know who the [ __ ]
you're talking about yeah and i said
you know it's really easy for you to
talk big right now on my [ __ ]
platform
because i'm the person that had to take
your bullets so you could go ahead and
say this [ __ ] with pride
when i was doing this [ __ ] you weren't
there with me when i was getting [ __ ] on
like who's this asian guy talking all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you know blah blah
blah
i had to take those bullets you didn't
have to yeah now it's easy for you to
say it because you had this whole
community
that people like me bart joe we built
this [ __ ] up
like i'm not saying i want that respect
but don't ever say that some respect of
my neighbor
put some respect on that [ __ ] yeah like
you don't
i'm the last person you get to say that
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
ever well not to mention not to mention
it is
not your sole responsibility to have a
reaction or to respond to
everything every injustice that happens
against asian people
you know it's like look sometimes
it might not even hit my radar some [ __ ]
that happens
right i mean it's not like you're
[ __ ] sitting there
like a social justice warrior just you
know looking for things to talk about
all the time about
social justice for asian people it's
like sometimes yeah
and i gotta sit and think with this
sometimes right exactly and maybe
sometimes you don't even wanna speak on
it publicly
and that's your decision that's your
prerogative
nobody has any right to be like oh
because you got this platform you
have to speak on it i don't have to do
[ __ ] i don't know
i don't have to do [ __ ] you suck my dick
yeah and i'll tell you this too
sometimes when you're asking some of
these influencers to speak about very
important topics
you know that some of the dumbest
[ __ ] people on earth i don't want
them to say [ __ ]
i want them to shut the [ __ ] up it's
better left
nothing being said exactly sometimes
it's better for you to say nothing at
all yeah and i've been on a whole tirade
about that when it came to politics i
put it on instagram
i'm like why do you keep going up to
influencers right these influencers who
are [ __ ] 13 years old
who have a career showing their [ __ ]
[ __ ] or putting pies in their face
saying hey
i want to know about your thoughts about
something as complicated as politics
because you have a platform at the same
time
they're dumb they don't know [ __ ] yeah
they should shut the [ __ ] up yeah
having a platform doesn't necessarily
equate to intelligence yeah
exactly and so it's
it's tricky man it's tricky because it's
like you know
you're you're in that position where
people feel like
they kind of have an open
invitation to like make suggestions or
like even demands of you to an extent
then at the end of the day too like yes
i do have this platform
and and yes i i i am i do have some sort
of influence
to like a group of people but at the
same time you're a [ __ ] human being
you know what i mean and people don't
realize too man one of the biggest
reasons why i stopped doing rants was
because
it started making me into a very
negative person like i just
i was doing it because i wanted to be a
voice for people who just couldn't
voice certain things but you have to
realize to yell at a camera
yeah for a living eats away at my spirit
oh for sure bro
like it's the opposite of like just
fake a smile even if you're not feeling
it just to get yourself to be angry just
to be angry
right you know you getting in that mode
is gonna [ __ ] trigger you whether you
like it or not
a hundred percent and i'm like i can't
keep doing this you know when i was
doing the
the stuff on my instagram about you know
specifically uh
a lot of black americans that were being
murdered by the cops people are like
hot it's like yo like how long did it
take you to write that i didn't write
that [ __ ]
i just said it you know what i mean did
you think i could
memorize a script that long and talking
to a camera are you [ __ ] nuts when my
rain man
you know what i mean not right what do
you think i'm doing here
when i look back and i'm like oh this is
really articulate but that just shows
how pissed i was right i mean it's
coming from a real and genuine place
i can't i can't do that when it's not
real it's going to come off hyper
disingenuous yeah to me too and it's
going to make me sick watching that it's
like david you literally did that
because you wanted views
right and you you didn't think about how
it would affect people mentally
you might be saying some [ __ ] talking
about angry stuff where somebody's day
was perfectly fine
and now they're pissed about stuff that
they shouldn't be angry about and that's
why i say
that is the [ __ ] biggest crime of all
going back to
you know some of the the people i was
mentioning people like
lauren like who are aware of this [ __ ]
they know
like they know they're intelligent
enough to know what they're doing
does not necessarily reflect what they
truly feel
like i'm not saying it doesn't reflect
some of it maybe maybe it
represents like 50 of what they think
and believe or thirty percent whatever
the case is
it's not a hundred percent as
controversial as
as like they make it out to be in their
mind and in their opinion but
because it sells because it gets the
views because it gets them clicks
because it gets them sponsors they do it
it is this toxic
[ __ ] thing that that i i only
i think i'm being more vocal about it's
just
this idea that money is everything
people keep pushing this idea and you
see it all the time in these memes it's
like
yo hustle until you got get your paper
up
hustle it's all about the bread if i'm
not getting paid it doesn't matter
who the [ __ ] are you who came up with
these sayings yeah you know what i'm
saying
it's like yo what and i guarantee you
it's the loser that made up these
sayings to the person without money
talking about this [ __ ] right
if you ain't helping me build my [ __ ]
empire then what is you doing in my life
your empire your empire now now
to be fair there are people who fake it
till they make it but it's a
small group of people very very small
group of people and they like they're
like well p
diddy said that's p diddy he say to
himself
he could do whatever the [ __ ] he could
say that he's a gajillionaire
yeah you are not you need to make sure
that you're in that position to be
giving that advice in the first place
right because i could go ahead and talk
about all these mistakes that i've had
blah blah
because i've experienced it i've done
this type of stuff before so i'm saying
it from a personal place
that's why i would have never been able
to do this podcast 10 years ago
because i wouldn't have this much stuff
to talk about yeah because of the 10
years of experience and all the [ __ ]
that i went through in these last 10
years
and so many stuff that i learned from
conversations with people um
you know doing stand-up traveling around
you know having some of the most
interesting stories told to me
i can now do this podcast for another 10
years and i still
won't have enough uh i still won't have
um i still
won't man i'm [ __ ] up whoa bro what
you're trying to do right now
i'm gonna edit this daddy chill
i still will have enough stories for
another 10 years because of everything
that i've experienced right
so yeah 10 years ago impossible for me
to do this podcast yeah because i might
have been able to do
an episode per week um
and i might have lasted a couple years
because i didn't have enough knowledge
to go ahead and form an opinion about a
lot of stuff
and a lot of the times too some of you
[ __ ] specifically on tick tock
like to give advice about [ __ ] that you
know nothing about
you know nothing about you no nothing
you have no absolutely nothing they're
not thinking about that [ __ ] though
they're just thinking they're just
caught up in the moment
you know like i don't think a lot of
thought
goes into what a lot of these people
with platforms do sometimes
it's just hot it's the hot yeah there
are there are other people who are crazy
manipulative who know exactly what
they're doing but then i'm talking about
like more younger people
it's just off the cuff man in the moment
how they're feeling
whatever thought that they saw this tick
tock you know the other day
and it got so many likes as if this
person was saying some mind-blowing [ __ ]
and it pissed me off so bad this person
said they're like
i can't believe in 2021 that we have to
say this like did you know
that you should respect women and i'm
like
well how how old was the person saying
it like 20s in their 20s
it's like that's a little too old it's
like it's
and people are like preach what preach
like this that's a given you're not
saying anything it's a given
what are you saying yeah it's just
you're just saying
[ __ ] that's already [ __ ] known and
it's a given like
what do you i'm about to be a tick-tock
star in a matter of a month
i'm about to say some crazy [ __ ] hey bro
i got these shoes i'll be lacing them
that's it you sure you want to do it at
the price of the chinese government
taking you in
i'm gonna start doing tick tock saying
some basic stuff dude so when i put my
pants on
i'll be zipping my nipples
just to keep on doing [ __ ] tick tock
parodies i mean making fun of other
people giving life advice yeah
did you know that i'm asian and i don't
need to take your racist [ __ ]
preach like the [ __ ] i don't know maybe
it's just me but like when i see
some of these videos of like you know
even this whole like
tick-tock dance [ __ ] right i mean that's
what really popularized the platform in
in like recent history right
it's just so cringe for me it is hyper
crazy
so cringe-worthy like i see these
[ __ ] young girls who are trying
to look all cute or like look all sexy
it's like oh my god oh my god dude
you're [ __ ] 16 years old or you're 18
years like
that is not something that you need to
be [ __ ] thinking about
to [ __ ] get these likes and these
follows from people like
but what are you [ __ ] doing this is a
young person's validation now this is
what it is
it is it's the [ __ ] hyper sexualize
themselves you know
and it's like it's so [ __ ] not only
is it cringe-worthy it's disturbing as
[ __ ]
because i look at it and i [ __ ] dread
oh my god if i ever have a kid and if i
have a [ __ ] daughter or a son
or [ __ ] you know i like if i saw my kid
doing that [ __ ]
i'd be like you just lost your privilege
to your phone for life
for 100 [ __ ] years you ain't ever
[ __ ] getting another phone as long as
i'm paying the bills
i mean it like i said that is what their
value is based on and i just don't want
it man and i've and i've seen parents
now
yeah who are doing a really great job of
not allowing their kids
to base their value on what they see on
social media because they monitor it for
sure
they have to and sometimes too like i
hear some of the dumb stuff from parents
they go oh you know it's like well this
is the trend that's going on now so i
don't want to stop it i want
you know they're gonna get on their
phone either way so i might as well just
let them do whatever they want because
that's just how things are and it's like
no or or even worse partaking in it
with like you've seen you've seen like
the [ __ ] daughter and mom combos
you know what i mean we're so cringy
dude oh
my god it's so cringy yeah i'm like dude
come
on like people it doesn't matter now
like
these platforms have allowed people to
get in any sort of fame
however the [ __ ] they were yeah yeah
straight up anybody that that
that was that's been the biggest in my
opinion
downfall to like our culture and society
it's really hard to find dope [ __ ] now
god [ __ ] it's hard man [ __ ] [ __ ] even
dope [ __ ] dude i just i just wanted to
stop
you know i just wanted to [ __ ] stop
man please stop
yeah just plea like [ __ ] pass some
i don't know man we we need we need some
we need some [ __ ] things in place to
limit this amount of [ __ ]
oh man i'm like even for me too just
because
you know as somebody who really i talked
about this on a podcast with mariel
where we were i was talking about how
the shittiest people with the worst
talent specifically when it comes to
singing are getting praised as if
they're great singers
and it's like no they're not i'm not
talking about mainstream artists yeah
i'm talking about people who just posted
yeah i know with the little ukulele
and they're like bro this is so amazing
like don't just say stuff just to say
stuff yeah
no but the the the part that bothers me
and it is like
[ __ ] sad is that they genuinely
believe that that
that is talent you know and and look
it's subjective right it's definitely
subjective
so so you know you can definitely say
that
uh see i don't even think that they
think it's dope i think that they
say that it's dope because it makes them
feel good about their [ __ ] talent
yeah i mean they're like oh like i kind
of sing like that that's pretty dope
then that's just lack of self-awareness
that's a lot of people though
because like once again it wraps back to
what we were talking about
because if they say that that person is
bad that means they're also bad that
means they can't be famous for doing
what they're doing too
so they'll rather push that mediocre
garbage up because it allows them to be
a part of something that they always
wanted to be but they know they never
had the skill
so we see a lot of bad [ __ ] all the time
right and then people are gassing up
this mediocre talent
like you don't have to say bad things
but you also don't have to say positive
things when they suck dick
that's true i mean it's it's i guess a
blessing and a
curse in that sense because it's like
some of these
truly talented people that you probably
would not have ever heard of
um had these uh you know outlets not
existed
but they're able to get exposure through
that
and and you know that when i see people
like that getting
getting um kind of the deserved
attention
based on their talent anyway like that
that makes me feel happy for them but
then you got these hacks
and it like completely blows my mind of
why the [ __ ] do people tune into this
[ __ ]
you know and i'm not just talking from a
music stand but just anything in general
like this is so [ __ ] cringe and so
not talent yeah but maybe it's just
because they look good
you know maybe it's a cute girl or you
know cute guy or whatever the case is
and they're just like oh my god this
person can do no wrong because
i find them so attractive for whatever
reason and
everything there's a girl on tick tock
like that right now where she literally
just mouths
uh songs and the camera zooms and
follows her face she has like a billion
followers
yeah yeah i mean like what the [ __ ] did
i just waste 10 seconds of my life on
you know that in front in that sense
it's never going to change man you know
attractive people are always going to
get attention
this is somebody else i'm just like yeah
i hope you catch coven
that's that's the new uh new thing for
you is i just hope you catch me yeah
of course kind of coming asian aids
you get that [ __ ] the china aids you
[ __ ]
talentless hack yeah i mean that's
that's you know goes hand in hand with
like the whole um self-worth and
self-identity thing too right it's like
they see these people
and maybe they recognize yeah they're
not really that talented but i mean
they're attractive and oh man it looks
so far i wish i was a hot guy dude yeah
you [ __ ] it doesn't matter what
i said on this platform
i could i could have just said some dumb
[ __ ] and you'd be like man this guy's so
smart
i know exactly what he's talking about
maybe
they'd be uh you know you'd be getting
dms
day and night bro i gotta drop 40 pounds
and get a [ __ ] uh tattoo on my arm a
whole sleeve
don't forget the you know face tats now
oh yeah that's really popular
all that [ __ ] dude well guys that wraps
up this episode of the genius brain
podcast
hope you guys enjoyed that episode what
if you agree or disagree about all the
[ __ ] that we're talking about
uh if you do disagree cool too if you
agree even better whatever the case is
guys
just love yourself man don't be don't be
so influenced by all these people
that are out there that have these big
platforms they're not they're not
like the they're the [ __ ] what do
they get to tell you what's what's
exactly exactly they're they're they're
no
they're yes they have a platform and
they have a following but
it doesn't mean that you should give
them the power
to like have that much influence over
you you should think about that
pick and choose love yourself don't fall
into these traps
that's all every thursday and sunday's
geniusbrain you can follow ed at ed2 and
at secret society
to cop that gear brain 15 for first time
uh oh bro yeah podcast listeners get 15
off everything i'm wearing right now
except my socks and my shoes you can't
have that but yeah
and we'll see y'all next time all right
peace peace